Instagram is absolutely cooked we need
to talk about what happened on Instagram
yesterday February 26 2025 you know and
I go on Instagram to post a video like
always but when the video goes live
comment started flooding in saying reals
turned dark why am I seeing and fights
on my algorithm bro Instagram turned
into a gors site breaking news many
Instagram users have reported extreme
content and violence on there for you
page Instagram officials have not yet
commented on the matter but are looking
into it so I head over to the reals Tab
and I kid you not it took one swipe to
find out what everyone was talking about
all right somebody tell me what's going
on because I just got a message from my
editor and he said yo you got to check
out Instagram so I open up my Instagram
reals and he was right it's literally so
much Gore content what is going on and
the more I scrolled the more sensitive
content I received the devil works hard
but meme Pages work harder and turns out
something did go very wrong at Instagram
but unfortunately it doesn't end there
because after digging a little deeper
this might actually be way worse than
just this one time glitch so every
social media company has their own uh
content moderation department where they
check if something is approved to go to
the public especially at certain certain
ages and whatnot and we really don't
think much of them but February 26
showed us why they're actually really
important um are you guys Instagram
users do you use Instagram much I have
an account but I never am on okay well
I'm an active Instagram user uh I don't
use Facebook only for like
Marketplace and I I stay with my age
group in Facebook I'm not even yeah yeah
Marketplace as well yeah or or Tik Tok I
don't really use Tik Tok either I
promised myself I wouldn't get entangled
with that because I already spent too
much time on Instagram unfortunately but
just like most people my age I am an
active uh Instagram user and yesterday I
noticed something funny with uh
Instagram but before we start a quick
disclaimer to parents this conversation
is going to get a bit heavy so if um you
have your children with you I would
recommend you watch this first uh this
is important important to parents as
well I think you should know what is
happening on your children's phones okay
what we're going to talk about here
today because yesterday I noticed that
uh every time I would go on Instagram it
would keep showing me sensitive um
content like openly like it wasn't like
blurred or like the eye you BL first yes
it would be blurred first but for in my
case most of the times it's just you
know probably martial arts or just
something that people ask like oh why
was it blurred right but then it was
actually um accidents people getting
hurt or and then it it escalated to
people dying you know a lot of uh fights
a lot of bar fights a lot of gunshots
and I thought it was weird it's like
okay I tried to skip and is the next
thing is right there I tried to skip and
it's blurred again it blurred again so
on the way home I go home with my
brother and and I mentioned to him and
he's like no my Instagram is the same
you know every two videos you got you
got to fight you got somebody die you're
like okay that's weird I live with uh
four other of my friends and they were
mentioning the same thing you know I was
I was making food at the kitchen and my
friend walks in with the girlfriend and
they're talking about about that I was
like wait you guys are talking about it
yeah did you see this video I'm like
yeah did you see that video yeah
everyone is watching the same videos and
then I went to search up and everyone is
talking about it on the internet get
fired I I am not sure what happened like
they don't moderate anymore somebody got
fired that position they just canned or
something well here's the thing the
whole internet is talking about it but
nobody knows what actually happen right
so we got a lot of videos these are all
different videos and this is my feed
okay this is all from my Instagram and
everyone is talking like my Instagram
for you page today for some reason
everyone fighting and killing themselves
me watching the world's population drop
by 50% on February 26 right and
everyone's sensitive uh topics and and
it it gots blurred right for some reason
look at that how I look at my phone
after seeing 48 naked people 589 fights
and 10 murders on Instagram today that's
scary that's everyone everyone was
getting that right for some reason and
you know it made news as well we got
business insiders saying Mega uh meta
apologizes for the sudden influx of
graphic content on Instagram R uh we
also CNBC talking about it people on
Reddit were going crazy to make sure
everyone was getting it okay so here's
what's really weird I I think there is
15,000 people that work for Facebook
specifically to actually float through
the content but that every piece of
content flows by a person who knows I
don't know but you but you've got you've
got people that that's their only job I
mean if if they're kind of random
sampling they would come AC you're
talking about billions of content that's
not gonna be handled by 15,000 people
well
algorithm Bots and all sorts of stuff
that are helping with that but but the
fact that that would make it past
without them calling yeah and being like
hey yo Mark Zuckerberg what's going on
yeah I mean there there are many
theories for sure on why this is
happening people say that um now with
Mark Zuckerberg saying that people will
be the ones now moderating content
instead of AI because you know free
speech and all that
but I mean it doesn't really explain why
everyone is seeing this on the same day
in the same videos and we're talking
about you know gory stuff everyone knows
on Instagram probably has seen a man
being stomped by an elephant and how
does something like this accidentally
happen I mean to me I guess my first
thought off my top of my head is like
are they testing to see or have a reason
to then monitor it but they create the
problem and they're like okay we got to
fix this thing and do this thing over
here and they can make this massive
change software date did they explain it
see um they just said it was like not
really a bug or something nobody knows
even when meta apologized they said like
the only thing they said is like oh
we're sorry for showing you things that
nobody should ever see that's it I I
wonder if that was just you joked about
this but like what what if there was
somebody who was uh Angry like oh
whatever and they had access to this and
they're like I'm just going to do this
and I'm getting fired anyway I don't
know I'm just saying like could be some
people are saying that the depart
Department of contard duration went on
strike as well so is there evidence for
that or there's no evidence and that
wouldn't suggest that all the content is
thrown out at once in one single day for
every single user right now it
it's I guess we could let it pass or not
consider it as much if this was the
first time it happened but interesting
interestingly enough the same thing
happened two years ago and what's the
date February
26 and this is the Washington Post
there's no way that my theory then
stands because it's not like on the
exact same day two years ago somebody
else got fired got angry did this there
there's no way but only two years ago
not last year no not I I don't know
about last year but I know that two
years ago Washington Post on the same
exact day it is weird it's kind of weird
right cue the eerie
music Big Brothers watching you right
exactly so what are the chances and and
when I was doing the research uh since
it was too recent there weren't too many
articles about this year's event about
what was happening what were people
seeing but um I read the article from
two years ago and ex is the exact copy
you know what else is weird if you look
at number one on the side there this
news article from two years ago down at
the bottom you know what else is in the
news Elon Musk and government funding
yeah right okay I I I have a problem
here how is it that you can say one word
and be taken off of YouTube or whatever
like this and they catch you immediately
okay not showing graphic things
immediately they can react to that but
you can't react to that see a lot of
that stuff I think is is Visual and I
don't think it's as good as detecting
visual as it does
audio yes yes I would say that's true
but we I mean we've said words and you
give flag for Words yeah that's audio
the fact but the fact that it blurs and
it tells you ahead of time this is
sensitive topic that is that is weird
they they know it is but they still let
give you the option to to just watch it
yeah how does it know it has to know
somehow if it has a bot that can monitor
what's being displayed yeah why why is
it showing that is weird yeah so I went
through this article and I wanted to go
through uh with you guys because it's
the the exact same thing that is
happening right now okay right so
obviously there are no pages on in
Instagram that are like person killing
right that's not the name of the the
account they're all meme accounts right
so uh Keith do you want to read this
page so meme pages are some of
Instagram's most popular destinations
amassing millions of followers by
posting videos photos and memes designed
to make viewers laugh or feel a
connection they account for tens of
millions of Instagram followers and
their audiences often skew very young
according to a survey from marketing
firm why pulse 43% of 13 to 17 yearolds
follow a meme account an age group whose
safety online is one of the few things
Democrats and Republicans in Congress
agree on to add to the concern the
majority of people running the accounts
are often young often teenagers
themselves those in the meme Community
say okay so we know that people who who
are on Instagram watching are you know
the majority are young teenagers and the
people who run them as well right so the
article goes on to talk about how meta
knows that they have this issue with
sensitive videos but they also say that
like according to uh what they saw this
statistics for every 10,000 content
views there's only about three that are
you know uh violent or have graphic
violence which you know seems like not a
lot seems like a drop in the bucket yeah
it seems like you know every 10,000
there's only three okay but what happens
is the people who are running these
pages right um can you read that denique
the administration for several accounts
posting Gore appear to be young men
which hagglethorn said is expected
because most meme administrators are in
their teens or early 20s the meme page
audiences are 13 to 17 year olds so the
people who run the page are young he
Thorne said it just you know what I
without going too much further you know
what it just smacks of Andrew
Tate I mean you wonder like is he behind
something like that you know what I mean
I don't know he did bring a lot of
people into watching Instagram I have a
hard time believing that somebody could
hack him no not hack him but use like
get to a whole bunch of young men as
like influencers
kind of a bunch of Stu and like it gets
pushed out there I don't know yeah he
did have a lot of influence and in in
this group age as well yeah right so not
only is the majority of Instagram users
uh 13 to 17 but the majority of
Instagram users who watch meme accounts
are 13 to 17 years old as
well right and uh can you read this
Scotty Instagram declined to meet with
the creators about their concerns the
content shared by a large Pages has only
become more graphic and violent if I
opened up Instagram right now and
scrolled for 5 seconds there's a 50%
chance I'll see a Gore post from a meme
account wear said it's beheadings
children getting run over by cars videos
of the most terrible things on the
internet and they're being used by
Instagram accounts to grow Their
audience and monetize that audience oh
that's gross early 20s people posting
two children to watch it is so if that
statistic is one in 10,000 shouldn't
that generally be like consistent with
everybody's phone Ian you know what I
mean not like one in 50 that's a big
difference between 1 and 10,000 50%
chance is not three and 10,000 yeah yeah
50% chance yeah that's even much higher
than that so yeah one and content that's
every other one yeah and the the minimum
age requirement for Instagram if I'm not
wrong is 13 so for them to say yeah the
ma is 13 17 is because they don't know
people younger than 13 watching this
right so there's no way to know if kids
younger than that are getting exposed
lying about their age when they sign up
yeah that's a really interesting thing
because you know this isn't happening if
the if the majority of Instagram users
are younger maybe that your earlier
Generation Um this isn't happening with
somebody with an older generation I
wonder if that same thing happened to
like parents or adults how quickly would
they respond to that I mean 13-year-old
doesn't know what to do you see all
those things and it's like who would you
call or complain to yeah well they might
not complain to anybody they might just
be intrigued by it they go there
expecting to see a meme because it's a
meme accounts they're all jokes they
they're cat videos they dog videos
babies laughing yeah you know they're
supposed to be funny videos and then
they kind of like not funny little by
little they go incorporating yeah and
also kids at that age when I was that
age you're you're interested in what's
going on around you're in the world you
know you're intrigued by it you're like
oh what's this I'm kind of curious cuz I
haven't explored the whole world yet
because my parents have refrained this
from me so now I have access to this I'm
going to watch it that's how kids react
like keeping them keeping them engaged
by Shocking them I I can still remember
before social media um back in the Stone
Age there was um there was a there was a
site called e-bombs world you remember
these what no you never saw that okay I
probably shouldn't be mentioning
sight but this was something that that
was like designed to be crazy videos on
on YouTube and I remember somebody
coming up at work we were all at work
and they were like did you know you
could watch somebody die on YouTube or
or whatever that yeah whatever that site
was I we should probably be careful
suggesting that because I don't know
what that site's turned into this is 20
years ago and um I can still remember
somebody coming up and showing me a guy
who stood on this guy's neck whipped out
a knife and then went to go to go SL SCE
his throat on camera and I just turned
away I I couldn't watch it and it was
just like I can't believe people would
watch this just to actually watch
somebody get killed I mean that's just
wrong no was EB bomb uh like a it was
like a website with shocking videos it
was like a public kind of like is it is
it commonly used by younger people yeah
I mean i' never heard of it before I
didn't even know that something like
that existed and they were there was all
these people standing around at work
like looking at these crazy videos now
imagine those type of videos being
promoted in a familyfriendly yeah child
uh
um like a lot of people yeah I've seen
Vice videos of people that work for
Facebook and other companies like that
that have to take down graphic things
got that's got to mess with your head
deess 100% 100% now the the last uh the
the next uh page goes on with the
article to uh mention a few of the
things that are being shown there and
the amount of life
okay so just want to say if for the
people who have a more sensitive stomach
I'll we'll put the time where you can
skip to this part of the video but I
just want to show what what especially
for parents you got to know what your
kids are being exposed to right so uh I
can read this the videos are truly
horrific in one video a bloody pig is
fed into a meat grinder it amass to over
223,000 views other real videos are
amass tens of thousands of views
show a woman about to be beheaded with a
knife a man being strung up in the
basement and tortured a woman being as a
several videos show men getting run over
by cars and trains dozens shows people
getting shot other real videos contain
footage of animals being shot beaten and
dismembered and then we got the the
caption for one of the videos watch
16-year-old girl beaten and burned by to
death by vigilante mob the caption of
one video reads showing a bloody young
woman being beaten and burned alive the
video was shared to an Instagram meme
page with over half a million followers
and that's the
13-year-old and and and this is a meme
account how many children are being
exposed to this goodness I think I just
got sick I know I just felt my stomach
turn that's
awful I'm I don't even want to read the
next part I don't even have a
word wow but it's really the last line
here people are commenting like I just
opened Instagram and the first post pops
up to be this and this happened two
years ago but it happened yesterday
again right and and and it's an age
where kids are being more exposed than
ever to technology yeah and it's being
masquerad into memes and funny videos
you know this propaganda happened in the
30s and 40s when Nazi Germany was coming
out they put a lot of propaganda and
basically disgusting things in front of
people and broke them down and those
people began to change in a very short
amount of time because then they were
able to carry out the ax themselves
exactly I mean they just were propaganda
like you know seen weird things like
this it is important to be careful what
we want with what we watch absolutely
but this is disturbing exactly I mean is
being we're being desensitized right
what does the Bible talk about uh can
you read that Scotty the of the body is
the eye and if therefore thine eye be
single the whole body shall be full of
light but if thine eye is be evil thy
whole body shall be full of darkness and
if therefore the light that is in thee
be Darkness how great is that
Darkness wow what they say the the eyes
are the window to the soul yeah right
and I mean little kids or even people my
age okay I'm not going to say only kids
are are uh scarred by that I'm 22 people
even older than me as well nobody should
be exposed to that especially bombarded
with this in a short amount of time so
is this continuing like if you go to
Instagram right now do you still see
these images um well so the news today
said that Mata fixed it but the thing is
you can build your algorithm based on
how many videos you watch so if
yesterday you actually spent your time
watching those videos it's likely that
you will still see them not as many
since they fixed it but you will still
see them here or there can you clear
that cash you can always go and in
parents is important for you to know
that you can always go on the post uh on
Instagram they're going to be the three
dots on the corner you can click that
and say not interest in this type of
content and it it should not show up
again that's a good tip that's a good
tip and it might be helpful to include a
video or a link a supplement a video
that shows parents how to do that
because a lot of parents you're on into
to they just they don't know the
technology well enough and Instagram you
know this type of content is not as
common as other type of content like
only fans Instagram is filled with only
fans
promotionals Tik Tok is too Tik Tok is
as well right so it's not don't use this
only for this type of content use them
for others types of you know uh what
what we call Brain rot yeah interesting
thing about this text I've used it it
many times but I usually use it from
Luke
11:34 and um always bring out that it
emphasizes that it affects your whole
body you think it's just you know
something going into your mind but your
mind affects the whole rest of your body
this going to physically change you y I
mean we we know the the scientific study
that we always talk about monkey see
monkey do if we watch our brain thinks
we are doing it and how do we feel after
doing something like that we don't feel
good I think there's real scientific
evidence of when you see the color green
it's like very calming on you that's why
a lot of earthy things are greens and
Browns um you feel differently when you
go camping don't you if you're bombarded
with like all this kind of stuff and you
just walk outside I I think you can
notice the difference that you feel and
so you know maybe a remedy is time to
unplug for a little bit oh yeah do a
fast do a fast if you if you've been
exposed to these things you know and
just unplug and go for a while without
it yeah many of the comments I was I I
would see these videos and I would open
the comments to see how people feeling
about this so many comments were like
okay that's it that's the last thing I
needed to be able to convince myself to
uh uninstall Instagram that's why I
don't like Instagram and and and get
give myself a break from social media
which was good but there was also a
comment that I thought was interesting
on one of the videos here highlight
um they said they want to desensitize us
something bad is coming so I thought
okay that is an interesting thought why
would they want to desensitize us right
and I mean you can see from the other
comments my rules are shootings and
fights an Indian guy got crushed to
death by an elephant uh 21 fights nine
guns uh four dead like they want to
desensitize us something bad is coming
like okay that's interesting what type
of bad do you know what happened earlier
this week in
Africa yeah I've heard of this 70
Christians were beheaded in the rep
Republic of Congo and nobody's talking
about it including Women and Children
Well now Fox news is talking about it
but you a lot of the mainstream news was
just silent on it I saw it on CBN what
country I got to go to Africa next
month well Democratic Republic of Congo
you're not going the DNC okay good DRC
sorry yeah so so I think it's really
interesting that I mean this would
people would be talking about it yeah I
think a lot of our news here in the US
is is overshadowed by political things
right now so that's what people are
looking at and and Hyper focusing on so
other things tend to go less noticed
yeah it just seems like no nobody is
carrying as much as they should 70
people including women and children yeah
they were surrounded by you know uh Isis
they were taken out of their homes in
the middle of the night and they were
all dragged to the church where they
beheaded one by one wow inside the
church wow right and it says world
mostly silent yeah right so what happens
when
we I don't want to say this has become
normal has become common but never
normal it's less shocking what it's less
shocking I I just what if the tables
were turned and somebody offed 70
Muslims do you think they'd sit around
and not do anything about it or say
anything about it like yeah I mean
nobody should have to experience that
but why isn't our world governments
stepping in in a situation like this and
being like you can't just off people in
your country you know isn't that a war
crime I thought it was is interesting
that like Hollywood always
they're always making a new bloody movie
to desensitize people I mean squid games
just came out and I mean if you ask me I
haven't seen squid games but my friends
uh have and they talk about how uh they
can't finish it because they're all kind
of like they become friends but they
have to kill each other in the end and
then everyone has to think about
themselves and it's just like wow wasn't
that desensitizing enough now you have
to show everyone dying on Instagram but
it's real life it's not a movie scene
right in a hundred different ways and
now we got this type of things and we're
just like oh okay just another Instagram
post type of news M yeah who who wants
to record that you know like who who I
don't know it just seems weird that
you'd want to record that right yeah
well that goes to show you know there's
some really good evidence between
violence and sexuality and when you link
those two things together it really
seriously burns the conscience and
there's a lot of there's a lot of times
if you if you talk to or about any
serial killer I remember that's that's
what um Ted Bundy when he came out and
he did his interview back then he said
it was a combination of sex and violence
and that caused him to become who he he
knew he was didn't Jeffrey dummer also
say that he watched movies in order to
get in the mood to killing people right
so this is not something that happened
to
Christians uh now but it's something
that is still going to happen okay so
Keith can you read these verses sure
Matthew 24:9 says then shall they
deliver you up to be afflicted and shall
kill you and ye shall be hated of all
Nations for my name's sake and Matthew
10:22 says and ye shall be hated of all
men for my name's sake that he that
endureth to the end shall be saved
amen notice how it says they be hated of
all Nations everyone is going to be
doing that because everyone is going to
be so desensitized by what they watch
now that when it
happens is just another news headlines I
was watching his video by a former
Israeli hostage she was taken hostage by
Hamas and she was sharing her story and
she said like they they just put her
into a room and and um you know the son
of one of the the guards would come in
and open a bag of candy in front of her
and just close and laugh and run off
when she was like bloodied and wounded
in this room and the wife of the Guard
wouldn't always feed her and she's like
it's like these people are just trained
from a child age to empathy no empathy
and you know when we talk about the
Bible there's there's going to be a
group called the
144,000 that those people in the last
days though everything will be against
them the Holy Spirit has been withdrawn
from the world um this group of people
um whether it's symbolic or not literal
that's another question but this group
of people will stand and they will not
sin anymore despite the worst situation
in the world and it's only by God's
grace that and we we have a video um on
you know can is it possible to overcome
sin we have a video on that and we also
have a podcast episode about who out
144,000 but you know this is going to
happen like it's going to get so crazy
but that means that today we have to
make a decision M what are we spending
our time on in the little things the
little decisions are we choosing
choosing God are we choosing God are we
choosing God or are we choosing the
little things matter are we choosing the
worldly things so that when the time
comes we will just fall along with the
world and not with God the Bible says
avoid the appearance of evil MH right
Den can you read this final verse for us
finally Brethren whatsoever things are
true whatsoever things are honest
whatsoever things are just whatsoever
things are pure whatsoever things are
lovely whatsoever ever things are of
good report if there be any virtue and
if there be any praise think on these
things we shouldn't really be um
watching things that don't fit into this
category right yeah and yesterday it
might have been un it was almost kind of
unavoidable for most people on Instagram
but if you see one if you see two it was
a 50% chance it said right two years ago
but from the first slide I showed
everyone was like one after the other
and my my fun was no different right
just shut it off just go outside like
you said Scotty go read your Bible go go
see some something that gives life right
not something that takes it away right
and yeah we just have to remain uh
faithful to what we know and not only
that um we shouldn't be desensitized
with this type of stuff as well
especially with the Christians that died
and we know that we should be a part of
that group as well Paul said if you
follow Christ you're going to suffer
persecution it's
unavoidable that's right so yeah I I
guess God wants us to be part of the
group that will stand firm and say hey
I'm not I'm not going to um just stand
by and let this happen mhm right I want
to be faithful to God and I don't I
don't want to see the devil having the
upper hand in this whether on social
media whether in real life or anything
like that yeah to ose you at this day
whom you serve you know you got to make
a decision because Jesus is this close
to coming back and I don't think we as
humans understand the urgency of the
times that we're living in to one share
the gospel and to to be right with Jesus
and to ask the the the question the
prayer I think it was David who prayed
that Lord search my heart and heart and
see if there is any wicked way in me and
show me so that I can confess my sin and
change
if you like this video like comment
subscribe and hit the notification Bell
so you know when we launch new videos
and drop a comments below and we'll try
to get back to you if we can
what say that again no no I don't know
what to say